i've i've read all of daniel craig's
weird ass interviews yeah you've seen
that man's interviews yeah yeah what the
[ __ ] is that man on
some of the [ __ ] this man saying
it's so funny
daniel craig articles were better than
the movie
reading these articles i got like 10
times more enjoyment reading these
articles oh yeah yeah did you read the
article where he was like i kiss
everyone on set did you read this
song
give your homies a little no no no no no
no it wasn't just it wasn't give your
homies a smooch it was like oh my god
all right i'm born james won
daniel craig and rami malik's claim the
pair kissed on james bonshoot i'm a very
friendly guy in quotes
who sent this randy malcolm
daniel
malik said craig grabbed him and picked
him up after he shed a good idea for the
movie
it's so weird
yeah yeah it's like it's so bizarre he
grabbed me pick me up and the moment
he grabbed me picked me up and i can't
tell who initiated them the next moment
whether it was him or i but a kiss
transpired between the two of us he said
what kind of kiss he said i'm gonna say
daniel craig i need to know how much
yeah yeah
what was it was like a full french or a
little second and mario making out yeah
they like ripped the clothes off i'm
gonna say that daniel craig initiated it
and i was very taken aback he added that
the kiss was he heard that the kiss was
very welcome and then at the time he yes
craig so does this make me a bond girl
and then this is a quote from daniel
craig i kissed him all right i kissed
lots of people crazy
it's like i'm a very friendly guy and i
wouldn't rank anybody
that would be that would be a terrible
thing a terrible thing to do
to rank the best kisses i would i would
just how many people could i offend
terrible thousands of people
oh my god
i understand what is going on on the set
of james bond
just going around to every actor like
have i kissed you yet not sure just go
around like just frenching people like
that's the audition process all right
yo you're suitable for the role
get daniel craig again
listen the stories had legs about
kissing rammy i've just been trying to
get it more legs i don't know if it's on
social media i haven't got social media
but i said i used to kiss rammy at the
end of every scene it's just like it's
just like not a big deal god almighty
just spreading the love
malik
[Music]
malik quipped i would just rush through
scenes just to get to the moment that
you would get kissed
what's good
wait so it's like wrapping mellick into
it as well he's loving it
the whole set is loving it sounds like a
[ __ ] love story going on yeah the
directors are like damn they're really
pushing through one take wondering it
was just kind of like why don't you just
like just just [ __ ] like
it was it was just such a bizarre read i
was like
what what
what is going on why are they sharing
this sounds like an onion i love it and
then i watched james bond then it was
nothing like that i watched james bond
and i would just imagine him at the end
of every scene i just imagine him just
running off and going making out with
malik
i love it i was like this is the best
article i've ever i've ever read in my
life i was laughing my ass off
like there's countless articles of from
daniel craig before this movie came out
of just like insane just losing his mind
just saying the randomist [ __ ] he just
brought up the one time he was like he
only goes to gay bars because it's more
friendly or something and i was like
what is it okay though right no no he
was like i feel more safe there other
people won't try and stop fights with me
i'm like what are you doing or you were
getting in fights in every bar i mean he
is james bond yeah
he's like 50.
is it just like method acting
i was like you're going to gay bars
you're kissing me like i'm like craig
man come on
come on just tell him what's going on
buddy like you wanted to say like it's
cool it's cool dude it's 20 21 bro like
just it's fine right i think it's going
to be my favorite daniel craig clip
though you guys know the weekend yeah
ladies and gentlemen yeah there's okay
and there's the weakness there's another
article where he didn't know about the
meme yeah they introduced the meme to
him yeah and he's like that's great
that's amazing
like daniel craig articles are better
than the [ __ ] movie
the article's ten out of ten the movie
was a five out of ten yeah
wait no did you
like a fan of the daniel craig james
movies like any of them
i was like never really uh like a
massive fan of james bond but obviously
i just feel like it's just not as
massive a franchise as it was when you
know we were growing up when are like
our parents ages yeah